everything changed when the slave Nation
attacked what used to be a thriving
colony is now a captured country
slaves do the work serving their new
Masters until they die only to be
replaced by new victims harvested in
brutal raids but let's go back to the
beginning
[Music]
the world war of the ants is claiming
millions of lives every day but in the
brutal world of ants straight up war is
not the only way around 50 ant species
practice slavery the most extreme
division of labor
we don't know how this began but some
ant species perfected this cruel trade
meet polyogus the most intense of the
slaver and tribes there are different
species but generally they're four to
ten millimeters long with round to
blackish bodies and sickle-shaped
mandibles polyergus have specialized in
slavery so much that they've lost their
ability to care for themselves
they don't clean build nests care for
their brood or feed themselves they only
exist for raiding
slaves make up 80 to 90 percent of the
ants in their colonies so a few hundred
polyergus and a single queen control
thousands of slave ants we'll summarize
and simplify what we know about
polyergus into one Grand Story you can
find more information in our sources so
now let's witness the cruel banality of
nature The Raid
it all begins on a mild Summer Morning
on a sunny field
witness this colony of over ten thousand
formica ants genetically cousins of
polyergus who build a thriving Nest
Underground
they are a widespread genas some species
are good Fighters some great Builders
and some cattle Farmers often welcomed
by humans because they hunt Vermin that
hurt forests nobody noticed the lone
polyager Scout that briefly showed up
this morning before she bolted away
again
the attack begins in the early afternoon
the Scout returned from her mission to
find the formica nests she dances
erratically and spreads pheromones that
excite and mass recruit more and more
ants until a large raiding party of a
thousand Warrior s's has formed a
close-packed well-organized column up to
10 meters long begins to move as the
polyacus raiding party arrives at the
formica Colony the attack begins almost
immediately
dozens of attackers begin digging and
clearing up debris from The Nest
entrance to make it easier to storm as
soon as they're done hundreds of the
attackers Rush inside
The Defenders vastly outnumber their
attackers and our formidable Warriors
able to shoot at it but instead of
fighting back effectively they seem
confused and Scatter rather than
fighting back
polyergus also seems to be somewhat
resistant to the acid sprays of the
Defenders and so even if a defense is
forming the attackers use their
mandibles to pierce and kill there are a
few different ideas as to why polygous
attacks are so efficient and one of the
most fascinating ones is chemical
warfare
instead of relying on Brute Force they
release a propaganda pheromone that
makes the Defenders Panic unable to
mount an organized defense
the attackers have nothing to gain from
intense ant-to-end combat other than
immense casualties what's more they
actually want their victims to survive
so that they can be rated again in a few
weeks as the raid unfolds the attackers
breach deep into the colony looking for
their most valuable possession the
coronis babies
they grabbed the pupae and larvae that
will make up the next generation of
formica and carry them out of the nest
hundreds are abducted and brought back
to the polyergus colony in this rate
alone well most of them a few unlucky
ones are eaten as a sort of snack the
surviving victims will be turned into
slaves
after about an hour The Raid is over and
the formica can begin to recover it
seems their only strategy is to make
even more ants a decent sized Colony can
forfeit thousands of pupae in a single
raiding season and still survive
although in this case while the raid was
going on something even more Sinister
happened
hold that thought though because how are
polyergus turning ants into slaves
how to brainwash and slaves ants
conquered almost the entire planet over
100 million years ago they owe their
success to being social animals that
perfected chemical communication
chemical signals and cues let ants know
what their colony needs and what each
individual should do and most
importantly in this case who is a friend
or Foe
slave making ants are much less social
than other ant species
some species miss a lot of the genes
other ants have to make communication
possible in a sense they are bad at
talking to each other so it may be that
as polyoga's ancestors started to abduct
other ants they lost the ability to
collaborate and work together
productively
soon after the stolen formica Offspring
have been brought to the slaver Colony
they are progressively covered in
polyergus pheromones
they are chemically imprinted similar to
a duckling who imprints on its mother
after birth
when the New Slaves hatch they behave as
though they are part of the polyogus
colony and begin to work for them
unconditionally keeping the nest clean
caring for the next generation of slaves
and Masters hunting for food and feeding
their enslavers mouth to mouth
this sort of brainwashing goes so far
that if they encounter free formica ants
in the world they will treat them as
animates in a sense they're not true
slaves as they serve willingly and show
no interest in Freedom it's more like
violent abduction and adoption which
doesn't make things that much better and
as the formica only live for a few
months a constant new supply of victims
is necessary to survive polyergus can
never stop enslaving
how to make new slave colonies
how are new polyogre's colonies created
after all polyerga's workers are so
useless that a queen can't start a new
Colony without slaves but how does she
make slaves without Warriors it turns
out there are two main strategies the
more dangerous one might unfold during a
raid like the one we witnessed before
a young polioga's Queen silently follows
the raiding party
using the chaos of the invasion she's
able to find her way to the formica
Queen and kill her taking over the
shaken Colony although such a victory
may be very short-lived polyagers do not
tolerate other slaver colonies within
their hunting ground they raid each
other fiercely too and can destroy the
competing colonies nearby so while this
tactic sometimes works it is pretty
dangerous another young Queen is going
for a different strategy
she's looking for a full Mica Colony
that is further from her birthplace
attacking a whole Colony on her own
she bolts through an entrance pushing
aside confused ants that try to stop her
releasing a powerful appeasement
pheromone that drives Defenders away
she has only a short time window to find
the formica Queen deep in the Hostile
Nest once she finds her Target both
Queens engage in a fight to the death
Queen is well equipped with her sharp
mandibles she bites and rips into her
victim for about half an hour before she
finally calms down between her bites she
licks the chemical surface of the Dead
formica Queen covering herself in her
pheromones
when she's done with this Macabre ritual
for Michael workers approach her subdued
by her intense smells they start
grooming and feeding her as though
pledging their allegiance to their new
ruler she still might not be done though
for Mike economies often have multiple
Queens who all need to be defeated which
is not guaranteed often attacking Queens
will be stopped by a Phalanx of workers
that rip her apart or are defeated in
royal battle
but if she does manage to kill all the
Queens The Colony has been taken over
and the enslaved brood will begin to
serve a new Queen the usurper
she now begins laying eggs that are
cared for by her New Slaves until New
polyoga's ants hatch that will soon
start new raids on neighboring colonies
no matter what we humans do quietly
below our feet the world war of the ants
is Raging with wild and horrible
strategies fought by billions of
individuals every single day polyergus
will continue to hunt for slaves as to
stop raiding would be their demise and
in the war of the ants there is no
giving up
we want to explore even more ant species
and videos to come but not just ants our
planet has so many more wonders to
Marvel at and learn about that is if we
manage to preserve their habitat and
turn the tide on climate change
something we're very passionate about at
kotskazat and have covered extensively
in past videos we've found a partner to
turn our dedication into action we'll
pay to offset one month of your carbon
emissions with the help of our friends
from Ren by visiting rendoco and
answering a few questions you can find
out your personal carbon footprint your
first step should be to reduce your
footprint but there are limits to that
Ren lets you offset the rest of your
carbon footprint with a monthly
subscription that supports projects that
plant trees protect rainforests and
remove carbon dioxide from the sky we
think it's one of the many puzzle pieces
that can make a real difference in the
climate crisis once you sign up to make
a monthly contribution you'll get
pictures and updates from the project
you support so you can directly see the
impact you're making
Rena is completely transparent about how
they spend the money and we especially
like their rainforest protection project
in the Amazon another amazing ecosystem
full of wonder we want coming
generations to learn about as well
wren's project trains indigenous
communities to use drones and satellite
imagery to detect deforestation helping
them protect their rainforest home sign
up through ren.co kotskazat to start
helping the planet as climate change is
close to our hearts we will personally
pay for the first month of subscription
for the first 200 people to sign up
right
[Music]